let me pull this up
the examiner actually says
many of the materials posted by 4chan
users match the contents the washington
examiner previously found on a password
protected iphone xs backup located in a
copy of hunter biden's abandoned laptop
konstantinos gus dimitriolos
uh i'm not going to read everything to
say but he's a cyber security expert
basically says definitively this is real
this iphone backup he said i conclude
the same results of the macbook that
it's uh it's real blah blah it is was
his his iphone now like it's one expert
opinion but we're getting there yeah i
say take it with a grain of salt because
i wouldn't be surprised if somebody
makes some fake screenshot of text
messages gets everybody to go nuts then
the media will come out and be like
proven false definitively and then try
and use it to discredit to ignore
everything else yeah and i i just want
to say too that i think when we're
laughing at hunter biden addiction
sucks and is horrible and i've dealt
with addiction and i've dealt with it in
my family and it's really sad and
depressing but i think that when we see
elites like this getting away with
things that your average person would be
completely shut down for arrested for
that's where it gets frustrating i got
it we got a fact check already it was
meth not crack
really
on the scale well you know then now he's
a party in that i feel stupid i know i
feel stupid i feel stupid though because
when i looked at it i thought it was
meth and not crack
but i'm not an expert on these things
see that's how and i'm a recovering drug
addict and elky but i never did meth
there was only one that i never did and
crack
i was surprised with it have you taken
an mdma oh yeah it's technically a type
of meth
yeah then i have
out there oh i'm sorry you don't want to
be like no no no no no no nobody wants
to be like
i saw a video of joe biden and it looked
like he was telling in front of congress
like i made the law that if you get
caught with this much you're going to
jail for five years and a judge can't
even oh my sister was juxtapositioned
with just
doing hunter doing all of it i i just
want to say to all the you know the
younger people who may be listening yeah
because this show is not for kids but
maybe your parents you need to
understand
you don't do drugs no because then all
the other kids will mock you and call
you hunter biden that's like the worst
possible thing again it's bad yeah
that's real bad you could be so popular
you do have to discern what the word
drug means because aspirin is a drug
black tar heroine is a drug that's right
okay
with the word kids written under yeah
it looks like a flintstone vitamin did
you wait wait hold on there was a
libertarian confession
you know this one right no i'm just
laughing at the setup true it's true
where uh was it austin peterson who said
don't sell hair when the kids and they
boot him in
it's like can we at least agree there's
a line there no no
all right
did you say at the beginning that the
secret service put out a statement
saying that his we have that let me let
me just cloud it so so this is these are
two different stories but they overlap
so uh secret service says it's aware of
alleged hunter by an icloud hack quote
at this time we are not in a position to
make public comments on potential
investigative actions
okay so 4chan says they cracked the
phone
now we have the icloud the difference is
the iphone backup was apparently on the
laptop so you know you know when you
when you plug your iphone in it's like
back it up it's on your computer and
then someone finds it they got to get
the code for it you do now
yeah with uh the icloud apparently it
says current icloud meaning
stuff you were sending a week ago or
whatever the crazy thing is now this
stuff needs to be verified but if it's
true
and the icloud stuff we we we we got to
get verification on
yo he calls his dad
he calls his dad
a person who abuses children i'll keep
it family friendly
his nickname in his phone is
you know now look we've all said mean
things to our dad in our worst faces
right this one's a little i've never
insinuated that either of my parents
were like child abusers before that's a
big kind of weird there's also uh
alleged search history for
underage underage is an understatement
like as underage as underage could
probably get really pre-medicine how do
you think that's why i'm saying it's got
we got to verify this because yeah you
can't just say yeah i mean but maybe he
saw all the videos that we've saw for
the last four years of him sniffing kids
he's like oh this is what i've done oh i
see i documented this
well that's that's what people saw
you ever see there was there's a family
guy joke where there's a murderer in
prison yeah and then he's like i wonder
what this feels like and he stabs the
phone stabs himself and he goes whoa is
that what i'm doing to people
that's what it's like joe biden has
never actually watched the video of him
sniffing these children yeah
reiterate what you said addiction is
horrific yes but that that the media has
been a lot of the media has been like
silent on this and hasn't even like
possibly maybe hunted brian as a problem
is what i'm laughing about it's insane
it's complete insanity yeah and it's
like the fact that he can totally get
away with it and we've just been locking
up black people indiscriminately for
like cracks since like the 80s
look we don't have to have a problem
with everything but my point
is no i'm with you like i'm i'm a
recovering addict so we make fun of it
in let's say these meetings i go to or
speeches that i do i make fun of myself
you do make fun of it it's not
necessarily fun to just punch at
somebody's addiction
but we are paying for this addiction i
mean there's a lot that goes in and the
media like you said has been hiding it
this entire time i think we're allowed
to make fun of it when we've been
funding it and look at what they've been
doing to the other side's kids i mean
they've been calling trump's kid a coke
head for what five six years now i don't
like making fun of people suffering from
addiction i don't either i've had more
than one friend die from heroin overdose
what what i'm making fun of is the fact
the president's son is protected by the
media
unwell uh his father is funding a lot of
the stuff but more importantly
that
okay so some of the allegations here we
we've seen reports okay so this is
confirmed from the laptop that hunter
shares a phone number with his dad weird
now in these leaks there is a text
message from hunter to his dad of him
engaging in let's just call it adult
activities and again a legend because we
don't know this stuff is true or not my
dad didn't even teach me how to shave
i'm almost jealous
but we do know from the laptop so so the
photo of hunter getting it on to his dad
might not be real the text yeah but we
do know there's a text from him to his
dad of
pornhub
that was from the laptop and that was
reported by a couple different outlets
so why would you send your dad that
information
so look i don't look
like
joe's dad i found a great video
real quick though so my concern here is
look i don't i want to make fun of the
guy for being sick no what i want to
call out is
j uh hunter may be doing business as his
dad with his dad's permission right if
he's using a phone number under his
dad's name
sending these links he's probably who's
he really sending them to is it
it may be his dad i mean he calls his
dad it's just okay allegedly he calls
his dad pedo
in the in so again not verified what a
clever nickname clever yes no one would
would suspect it not a man of metaphor
no would you take out the d
wink
i think
hunter and joe
are using the father-son relationship so
that hunter can do the business dealings
that joe can't yes yes but it's
effectively joe doing the deals yeah
i think so too i mean even in uh the
book uh oh i'm blanking on the name of
it laptop from hell i mean that's kind
of what it's alluded to anyway why would
you pick your most unstable son to do
all the shady business because your
other one's dead
you're giving all the shady jobs to the
kid whose password i'm sure is give me
more crack one two three four it's like
how do you hack it but joe's password is
wrong kid dude
the alleged password was um
it was something really bad too really
yeah
it was the reference to the age of a
woman
so allegedly yeah i don't know how is it
but i i looked at some of the claims and
accusations it's a lot of a lot of
outlets are picking up the accusations
and they're all saying like this could
be fake but apparently the password was
uh uh i don't want to say it because
it's not my business but it was it was
like the password was a woman and her
age really like
but yeah unless it was the number was a
reference something else was it at least
double digits it was good and it and it
was at least
post-pubescent yeah that's good that's
great that's good my man's growing up
it's possible that this is a setup like
because it makes him look very deviant
and it makes joe look like he said pito
peter whatever the name he had for his
dad
and he's got his password is like a
young girl like that is it's not it's
beyond the detail adult age it's an okay
but a young adult
i guess yeah like like like the drug
addiction stuff i see what you're saying
where it's almost a little too on the
nose
um
it's very it's so bizarre but he left
his laptop like he left it somewhere
i just wanted three of them i want all
of you to know yeah what i sacrifice for
all of you
i want you to know this so become a
member at teamcast.com because i had to
look at all of these photos of naked
hunters
i'm like looking at these stories and
i'm like i i have to i have to either
because if people are claiming it's
there and i'm not doing my due diligence
so
ten dollars a month
i had to do it a bunch too yeah
i'm gonna have to do it later tonight uh
hold on we're gonna need to take a break
and i'll do it right now i'm pretty sure
the daily caller published an uncensored
image of hunter biden holding himself oh
no but because he was partially
underwater
the water kind of obfuscated it and i
was like did they think you couldn't see
what he was doing because you can yeah
yeah i think it was the caller touching
his dad's leg hair
when he was talking about the kids
rubbing his hairy legs he was referring
to his own children oh no
uh uh in all seriousness i'll say it
again i think joe abused his kids yes
yeah i do yeah hands down i think
so the reason why hunter's so screwed up
why does hunter call his dad allegedly
call his dad pedo if he really does this
and that is true that combined with
everything else we know i think joe
sniffed his son a little bit i've heard
that ashley biden's diary now this is
like a thing i don't know if it's real
or fake or what but i've been reading
stuff about it that she also implicates
her dad in this spot in this diary i
have never seen the diary i don't know
if it's real or not no i've heard the
same thing though
i think you might be right
he looks like gary oldman in hannibal
have you noticed that that's kind of
what joe biden is turning into just this
monster
yeah like if you look at him in hannibal
like he just looks like that and i
really do think it's all his secrets
just coming into age the picture is
great yeah like he looks like him it's
really and the more he talks because now
like especially in the top rod
top right you tell me that's not joe
yeah
that is totally joe
yeah
look at the tie oh and the tie for sure
the pigs will eat anything yeah
oh yeah yeah that guy came right a
bicycle
no he's falling right off a bike
i thought it was going to be an image
it's him after falling
can we we should get this one i thought
it was going to be a picture of gary
oldman not some disfigured you know no
no no mason burger i'm wonderful a lot
of people watching were just like yo i'm
trying to eat yeah yeah sorry if you
were trying to but it looks just like
the president so it's fine
he got all that face work done yeah he
really did you see the uh uh when he
said end of quote repeat the line oh
it's the best it was the ice i called it
guys i called it the white house in the
transcript
wrote let me repeat that line yeah all
right let me repeat the line
oh so they changed the character in the
transcript they changed what he said
yeah because they're trying to cover it
up i remember when government meant
integrity no no at least i thought it
did i swear if they show the podium it's
just gonna be one of those things where
you pull and it's like the cow says move
yeah it's just
like it's in it when like the salute the
troops thing it goes right back to that
where it's like say salute the troops
he's like salute the troops or he's like
instead of saluting right right
you ever see like the animatronic
you know uh chuck e cheese things
playing guitar yes like that's what joe
biden is yes oh yeah like behind him
it's all exposed metal in like yeah
just turns him on he's just playing the
piano
yeah the old-timey like
but i love i love how he actually said
end of quote repeat the line yeah and
he's like end of quote repeat the line
and then the same quote plays and it's
like
anybody who's sane saw that and laughed
like i know people who are like democrat
liberal leftist everybody was like it's
so it's so dumb we know joe biden's out
of it only 26 percent of democrats think
he should run again they're under no
illusions this man is capable they'll
they'll take something else but the
media is still trying to pretend like
anyone is falling for it i guess 26 of
the democrat voters are really
pretending yeah or really pretending i
was a little surprised um greg price
posted that quote and it got a lot of
traction and i noticed that the top one
of the first comments you see is one of
the white house aides saying that's not
what he actually said and giving her
version of it which is the version that
ended up being in the transcript
the people that are still so
blindly tied to biden are inferior like
when i posted that stuff of me and tulsi
i had a friend reach out to me just
unloading uh tulsi is the reason that
roe v wade got over to it it's like it's
like it's like the people who still
blame susan sarandon if it wasn't for
susan sarandon and it's like guys if an
actress if an old lady actress can
derail your political party your
political party sucks period if you are
still blaming tulsi gabbard who's
literally not in office right now i did
a comedy sketch with my friend and
you're unloading on her instead of i
don't know the president of the united
states who actually has power right now
like there are still people on the left
who are so in denial and just refuse to
hold biden accountable for some reason
when biden isn't giving them even
anything they want but they're
technically right
tulsi broke a lot of people out of the
cult
she she went up and she uh she
represented much of what the left was in
this country especially during the late
2000s early 2010s actually anti-war
actually anti-war actually calling out
the machine she's got some policy
positions that conservatives wouldn't
agree with she was pro-choice
traditionally like safe legal rare she
was for gun control she opposed nuclear
power i don't know where she is on those
things now yeah but that's like the
traditional democrat position with the
weird movements the democratic parties
made to try and pander to whatever it is
they're trying to pander to she stayed
where she was yep she said kamal is
awful what are you doing yeah and the
machine got angry with her because they
were trying to move in some weird
direction which by the way the reason
she was calling out kamala was actually
from the left about some of the horrible
stuff kamala did in california to poor
communities enslaving people yeah
yeah not a not a great one like actually
keeping people in prison longer so she
can use them for cheap firefighter labor
yeah but it was for dime bags so it's
cool yeah yeah right yeah it all made
sense she's a good person so yeah so
i'll so i'll hope she's president this
is why your friend
that's why you might get your wish here
in the next couple of years next five
minutes
this is why your friends manage to eat
soup yeah not because
tulsa is a russian asset but because the
people who want to maintain the cult
don't like it don't like apostates right
you've seen like
the scientologists
react to people that try to leave the
scientist there's a what was the girl
rogan
tell all what her experience in the cult
and out of the cult and the way that
they chased her down i mean they would
literally chase people to stop them from
leaving the physical location imagine
what they would do mentally if they're
willing to physically try and stop
someone from leaving the building right
like that's that's just thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you